aquí tenemos 6 distribuciones diferentes
y lo que vamos a hacer será pensar en
cómo clasificarlas o usar las palabras
que se usan típicamente para describir
las veamos la primera distribución es de
la longitud de las moscas alguien se
tomó la molestia de medir la longitud de
un montón de moscas y encontró que hay
muchas moscas cuya longitud está entre
seis y seis y media décimas de
centímetro al parecer hay 40 moscas en
este rango de longitud si vemos cuántas
moscas tienen una longitud entre seis y
media y siete décimas de centímetro
vemos que hay unas treinta moscas y si
queremos ver cuántas moscas miden entre
cinco y media y seis décimas de
centímetro
vemos que hay la misma cantidad bueno
pues a este tipo de distribución se le
llama distribución simétrica por qué se
llama así porque si dibujamos una línea
a la mitad de esta distribución vemos
que a un lado aparece la imagen espejo
del otro en este ejemplo la distribución
se ve exactamente simétrica pero al
recolectar datos es más común encontrar
distribución es que sean aproximadamente
simétricas ahora
la segunda distribución que se refiere a
las fechas de las monedas alguien tomo
un montón de monedas yo la fecha de cada
una y encontró que muchas de ellas al
parecer un poco más de 55 monedas tenían
una fecha entre 2010 y 2020 mientras que
muy pocas monedas tenían una fecha
anterior a 1980 este tipo de
distribución donde vemos una cola hacia
la izquierda se le llama distribución
asimétrica a la izquierda aquí está una
larga cola hacia la izquierda y en
futuros vídeos veremos algunas
definiciones más técnicas de por qué son
asimétricas a la izquierda pero mientras
tanto pueden reconocerlas porque la
mayor parte de los datos en la
distribución están del lado derecho
mientras que hay una larga cola que
disminuye hacia la izquierda y si hay
distribuciones asimétricas a la
izquierda también hay distribución es
que son asimétricas a la derecha son lo
opuesto a esta distribución y es lo que
vemos en esta distribución de aquí abajo
esta es una distribución de legisladores
por estado y vemos que la mayoría de los
estados en eeuu tienen entre 1 y 10
legisladores en esta
vemos que hay un poco más de 35 estados
en eeuu cuya cantidad de legisladores
cae en esta categoría ninguno de ellos
en realidad tiene cero todos tienen al
menos un legislador pero caerían en esta
categoría
vemos que muy pocos estados tienen más
de 50 representantes aquí es obvio que
la mayor parte de la distribución se
encuentra del lado izquierdo y vemos que
disminuye formando una cola a la derecha
así que esta es una distribución
asimétrica a la derecha ahora veamos
esta otra distribución y los invito a
qué pausa en el vídeo y traten de
clasificarla imaginemos que tomamos nota
del número de tazas de café que toman
las personas en una oficina en un día si
encontramos una persona que debe solo
una taza de café la podemos representar
con este punto si encontramos otra
persona que bebe una taza de café al día
la representamos con este otro punto
luego encontramos tres personas que
beben dos tazas de café y las indicamos
aquí viendo la distribución nos damos
cuenta de que es algo muy parecido a la
distribución de las fechas de las
monedas una gran cantidad de los datos
se encuentra en la clase de la derecha
la de las
tres tazas de café y la distribución
disminuye formando una cola a la
izquierda así que es una distribución
asimétrica a la izquierda
por último veamos estas dos
distribuciones que quedan y que son
bastante interesantes alguien podría
decir que esta distribución la cual nos
muestra el número de días que tuvimos
diferentes temperaturas máximas se ve
bastante simétrica es más si dibujamos
una línea a la mitad de la distribución
vemos que cada lado parece una imagen
espejo del otro así que se ve
exactamente simétrica eso no es
técnicamente incorrecto pero cuando
vemos estos dos picos típicamente es más
común llamar a esta distribución bimodal
así que aunque una distribución en
bimodal también puede ser simétrica o
aproximadamente simétrica debemos ser
más precisos y cuando tengamos estos dos
picos que por cierto de ahí viene el
vino la llamamos bimodal qué tipo de
datos podría representarse con esta
distribución pues se me ocurre como
ejemplo el que haya muchos días
calurosos en verano y que también haya
muchos días fríos en invierno en la
última distribución la de los
de tirar un dado también podríamos decir
que es una distribución aproximadamente
simétrica pues si dibujamos una línea
punteada en medio de la distribución
vemos que los lados se parecen mucho
aunque no son exactamente iguales pero
una clasificación más exacta de esta
distribución sería que se ve
aproximadamente uniforme con esto
describimos mejor esta distribución que
si decimos simplemente que es
aproximadamente simétrica con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo